pour ça puisqu'on place rien dit très
bien merci beaucoup c'est la fin de
cette émission merci pierre bernès elle
nous avoir accompagnés pour décrypter
les conséquences économiques donc lié à
cette pandémie de coronavirus merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette émission je
rappelle que vous pouvez voir ou revoir
cette émission consacrée donc au
coronavirus sur rt france pour tv vous
pouvez ici aussi réagir à cette émission
avec le hashtag rt cash
olivier comme le veut l'usagé le mot de
la fin est pour bat écoutez il ya une
pénurie de j'ai le droit l'hydro
alcoolique
donc je vous conseille de mettre du
pastis dans l'eau ça vous fera un sérum
hydro alcoolique avec modération
voilà
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord ici qu'on invite les plus
compétents pas seulement ceux qui
parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs parce qu'ici seul interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ces séquences sont uniques car
habituellement les territoires tribaux
de zoé ne sont pas accessibles au public
eric peut s'y rendre parce que c'est le
médecin personnel de la tribu zoé
les gens disent ils le connaissent tout
simplement comme le docteur éric il est
riche célèbre et il est toujours en
mouvement
à la barre de yachts et d'aéronefs
[Musique]
j'ai du mal à croire que c'est laid
masami
il n'y a pas de forêt
il est considéré comme l'un des
meilleurs neurochirurgien du brésil
[Musique]
ce qui se passe en amazonie c'est que
nos ressources sont exportées du brésil
il ne reste rien pour la population
rien ne revient à la population de
l'amazonie
[Musique]
une faible participation pour ce premier
tour des élections municipales en france
près de 39 % des inscrits avaient voté à
17h ses 16 points de moins qu'il ya six
ans un premier tour maintenu avec une
incertitude sur la tenue du second tour
puisque la france et risque de passer en
confinement total dans les prochaines
heures
le candidat des partis politiques
réduisent leurs soirées électro
électorale au minimum un nombre record
de décès quotidiens en italie fermeture
des frontières en allemagne les
simulations des épidémiologistes sont
alarmantes en l'absence de mesures
radicales de prévention après la
fermeture des lieux
leak en france lieux publics non
indispensables hier les tribunaux sont
clos à partir de lundi le confinement
total et l'interdiction de se déplacer
est envisagé ce soir
[Musique]
et
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france
bonsoir miley bon soit olivier et on
commence donc par ces élections
municipales en france avec un très
faible au taux de participation dans un
contexte de pandémie de coronavirus les
bureaux de vote des grandes villes ont
fermé à 20 heures on va faire le point
tout de suite avec notre reporter mona
nous dès lors au ministère de
l'intérieur
bonsoir monaco vous suivez donc cette
soirée électorale quelque peu
particulière où en est on de la de la
participation ce soir
eh bien écoutez les chiffres viennent de
tomber à l'instant même avec aliot qui
est du rassemblement national avec 33%
ce ne sont encore que des estimations et
pujol de l'est républicain avec 18,8
pour cent ces résultats sont
susceptibles de changer et il ya ce
second chiffre qui est un record
également le taux d'abstention avec 54,5
elles ce sont des estimations d'ipsos
donc au moins d'un électeur sur deux
s'est présenté à ce premier tour en
réaction aux annonces également
d'edouard philippe et cette épidémie du
corona virus qui touche tout le pays il
faut le savoir
ce premier tour a été largement décriée
par plusieurs personnalités politiques
que ce soient de l'opposition ou de la
majorité gouvernementale il avait
demandé un report de cette élection
municipale notamment de ce premier tour
les français se sont également exprimés
sur les réseaux sociaux à l'aide du
hashtag de jeu et n'irait pas voter il y
avait également 7 c'est ce groupe de
docteurs qui ont également essayé de
dissuader les français d'aller voter en
leur expliquant qu'il fallait rester à
la maison
en tout cas 47 millions d'électeurs
étaient attendus pour ces élections
municipales et qui dit contexte
particulier dit également mesure
particulière puisque dans les bureaux
doit-il fallait se laver elle
les mains avant et après avoir voté il y
avait des linges et hygiénique étaient
distribués il fallait également
respecter une distance de sécurité
plusieurs mesures respectée dans
certains bureaux de vote et dans
d'autres apparemment selon certains
internautes qui n'étaient pas respectées
on a pu aujourd'hui rencontré quelques
électeurs qui étaient dans la journée
allez voter certains étaient satisfaits
de ces mesures et d'hygiène d'autres
étaient un peu plus inquiets et écouté
je tiens le bureau de vote avec d'autres
collègues dont je pense que c'est un
devoir citoyen bon je pense qu'ils ont
laissés ouverts les commerces de bouche
les transports sont ouverts donc je vois
pas pourquoi il y aurait plus de risques
dans un bureau de vote d'autant plus
qu'un certain nombre de mesures de
sécurité sont prises pour que les gens
soient pas les uns contre les autres
ce matin je t'ai dit sur café n'était
pas ouvert non non non je savais
dernière gravement malade j'ai failli
mourir donc la nes et c'est pas pire 1
cette année
le virus qui courent c'est pas pire de
ce que j'ai eu je pense qu'on aurait dû
reporter ces élections purement et
simplement
[Musique]
parce que il est vraisemblable qu'on va
pas pouvoir faire le deuxième tour et
qu'on va se trouver dans une situation
politique assez inextricables pas allés
voter je pense qu'au fond nous on fait
attention reste à une distance d'un
mètre et des marquages au sol donc ils
ont bien prévu je trouve ils ont mis du
de la solution hydroalcoolique pour se
désinfecter donc je trouve tout le monde
respecte bien les consignes alors juste
pour vous donner une petite idée du taux
d'abstention dans les autres grandes
villes prenez par exemple limoges avec
63,9 63% pardon pour ajaccio 63,1 %
rouen 62% et enfin besançon avec 61 %
dont l'ombre du coronavirus a plané sur
ces élections municipales puisque même
plusieurs candidats ont dû annuler leur
soirée le dispositif de soirées
électorales dont rachida dati agnès
buzyn ou encore martine aubry et on va
suivre évidemment l'évolution de cette
soirée merci beaucoup mon amour on va
voir en détail effectivement les
premiers résultats candidat par candidat
olivier alors effectivement ratou
d'abstention tout d'abord qui s'élève à
54,5 % un taux d'abstention fort et puis
les premiers chiffres qui viennent de
tomber un tome abonnés oui les premières
estimations avec évidemment le premier
ministre edouard philippe qui est en
course au havre il récolterait donc
selon les premières estimations 43 % des
suffrages il est suivi par le candidat
pcf qui récolte serait lui aussi donc 34
% d'autres résultats dans d'autres
villes à noter donc par exemple qu'à
hénin beaumont steeve briois serait
réélu dès le premier tour ce sont
toujours des estimations et puis on a
des résultats également à perpignan où
louis aliot lui également représentant
du rassemblement national récolterait
entre 33 et 36 5% des suffrages
merci beaucoup thomas chiffres également
important concernant ces élections
municipales oui en fait on va faire un
point sur tous ces chiffres qu'il y a
vingt mille sept cent soixante cinq
listes qui ont concouru pour ce premier
tour
élection municipale ce qui représente
900 2465 candidat c'est 3% de moins par
rapport à 2014
au total dont 47 7 millions de personnes
inscrites sur les listes électorales on
a vu donc plus de la moitié s'est
abstenu ce dimanche 34 1967 commune où
on vote
c'est un chiffre qui est en dessous des
36000 communes que compte le pays c'est
parce que en fait il ya des communes qui
ont fusionné qui donc on vote pour deux
communes en réalité lorsqu'on est donc
appelés aux urnes
et puis à noter également que 106
communes n'ont ni liste ni candidats
pour ce premier tour de l'élection des
élections municipales alors parmi les
résultats qui seront particulièrement
observés thomas geha les villes bien
entendu où des membres du gouvernement
sont candidats on a parlé il ya donc le
havre le premier ministre s'est présenté
pour ce premier tour des élections
municipales je vous le rappelle selon
les premières estimations il récolterait
43% des suffrages l'on peut penser à
d'autres ministres qu'il ya par exemple
gérald darmanin ministre des comptes
publics qui est en course à tourcoing
alors lui il a déjà fait savoir qu'il
pourrait quitter le gouvernement s'il
venait à être élu à la tête de la ville
donc de tourcoing autre ministre qui est
en course c'est franck riester le
ministre de la culture il est en cours
celui à coulommiers une campagne un peu
particulière pour le ministre de l'eau
culte de la culture puisqu'on le
rappelle il a été testé positif aux
qu'ovide 19 et il sera pour sa part
numéro 2 en cas de victoire et puis on
peut évoquer d'autres ministres qui ne
sont pas tête de liste cela mais qui
sont sur des listes il ya par exemple
sébastien lecornu le ministre en charge
des collectivités territoriales à vernon
ou encore marlène schiappa qui est en
course sur une liste dans paris 14e un
mot enfin pour vous dire que 63 députés
son candidat lors de ces élections
municipales plupart des députés de la
majorité 30 parlementaires estampillé
majorité prix d'entrée zid en ciel qui
brigue d'une mairie et voilà donc pour
les personnalités du gouvernement et de
la majorité qui sont en course pour ce
premier tour des élections municipales
merci beaucoup thomas thomas bonnin on
va vous retrouver un tout au long de la
soirée pour nous faire vivre en direct
les estimations de cette élection et on
va les voir justement ses ministres
candidats quelques-uns d'entre eux
justement qui ont voté aujourd'hui
qu'ils ont montré
exemple en ce jour particulier de
pandémie de coronavirus ils se sont donc
succédé dans les bureaux de vote a
commencé par anne hidalgo qui a voté
dans le 15e arrondissement de paris la
maire sortante qui a suivi les mesures
de protection mises en place vous le
voyez des bureaux de vote vide
legault pour lutter contre la
propagation du coronavirus anne hidalgo
qu'elles soient ou non en première
position ce soir devrait appeler les
écologistes à s'allier à ses listes pour
faire bloc face aux candidatures les
républicains ou de la république en
marche
et puis magali dans le 5e arrondissement
de paris la candidate agnès buzyn elle
s'était également rendu aux urnes ce
matin à l'ex ministre de la santé avait
donné en troisième position du premier
tour agnès buzyn qui a annoncé exclure
toute alliance avec la candidate les
républicains rachida dati au second tour
elle compte proposer des alliances
d'arrondissement en incitant tout ce
qu'il souhaite à la rejoindre autour
d'une majorité de projets qu'il soit
issu de la gauche des écologistes du
centre ou de la droite
et puis l'ancien garde des sceaux
rachida dati a voté depuis le 7e
arrondissement où elle est candidate à
sa réélection
la maire sortante les républicains en
place depuis douze ans a voté en
respectant l aussi les consignes
sanitaires
l'ancien ministre de la justice de
nicolas sarkozy est plutôt bien
positionné dans les derniers sondages
mais ce sera plutôt compliqué selon les
sondeurs au second tour pour elle faute
d'alliés dans cette course pour briguer
le siège de l'hôtel de ville
aurélie gros conseillère régionale
d'ile-de-france et présidente du
mouvement la france vraiment est avec
nous par téléphone
aurélie gros bonsoir bonsoir
alors un premier tour dans une
atmosphère très particulière
oui effectivement la crise sanitaire qui
secoue aujourd'hui on peut le dire le
monde entier et particulièrement la
france nous a vraiment mis nous élus
devant un choix vraiment difficile pour
le coup c'était soit d'annuler
clairement les élections municipales
mais elles ont été maintenues et je
crois que ce soir il faut déjà salué
l'ensemble des bénévoles qui ont
participé à ces opérations électorales
signer une grosse incertitude ce soir
aurélie grobon soit le confinement total
qui risque d'être annoncé dans les
heures qui viennent un premier tour qui
s'est tenu au risque de ne pas avoir de
second tour
comment est ce que vous vous analyser
comment est-ce que vous appréhendez
cette situation la situation que de
savoir qu'au vue au vu de ce premier
tour où un certain nombre de maires vont
était dû au premier tour dans certaines
communes il ya que deux listes donc des
mers - était dû d'autres vont devoir
passer un second tour mais avec un
confinement effectivement maintenant
nous les élections du premier tour même
de ceux qui ont été élus au premier tour
ou est ce que on va devoir tout annuler
c'est vrai que c'est un casse tête
monstrueuse dac est la vraie question
c'est est-ce qu'il fallait maintenir
réellement ces élections au cul la
situation alors justement au rayon le
constitutionnaliste jean philippe
derosier affirmé cet après midi sur les
réseaux sociaux un qu'un report du
second tour annulerait de facto les
résultats de ce soir
oui oui oui mais j'ai géré entendu la
même chose que vous après j'en ai
entendu d'autres qui ont dit que ce qui
était dû vraisemblablement que ne serait
pas annulé
bon après je crois que de toute manière
la situation de la france n'est pas aux
élections et là je crois qu'il ya des
choses beaucoup plus importantes et que
si un confinement est annoncée il fera
tout ce qu on se plie à ce confinement
et s'il faut repasser aux heures de
repas sera tous aux urnes
on a on n'a vraiment pas le choix que
quelque chose de catastrophique moi je
j'étais étonné alors c'est vrai que
tendon commune on a eu un taux de
participation assez important au
coudray-montceaux on les a quand même à
48,73 % ce qui n'est pas rien au vu de
la situation se dire qu'il ya une perte
de 10% des lectorats dans d'autres
communes de l'essonne il ya des taux
même plus
important que cela après si les
élections doivent être annulées et on se
pliera à la loi et à la constitution
on peut on ne peut rien faire d'autre
aujourd'hui mais aujourd'hui ce qui
compte que la santé des français
clairement c'est la santé des français
donc effectivement le confinement risque
d'être est annoncé très prochainement et
je crois que c'est une solution à
laquelle on n'échappera pas et tant
mieux pour la santé de ses concitoyens
merci beaucoup aurélie gros d'avoir
commenté ces premiers résultats en
direct sur l efficience
merci beaucoup et au havre selon les
premières estimations le premier
ministre edouard philippe devancerait
jean-paul lecoq il aurait obtenu 43%
contre 34 pour le candidat communiste on
en a parlé avec thomas gonnet sur ce
plateau vous voyez le premier ministre
qui s'est rendu très tôt dans son bureau
de vote ce matin et il a bien sûr
observer scrupuleusement les gestes
destinés à freiner la propagation du
coronavirus après avoir voté
électroniquement il a sorti un stylo de
sa veste pour signer la liste
d'émargement
il est maire de la ville il a été maire
de la ville de 2010 à 2017 edouard
philippe qui annonce qu'il ne siègera
pas à l'hôtel de ville s'il gagne
évidemment cette élection il restera à
matignon et puis notre ville scruter un
de près lors de ces municipales magali
c'est à la ville de lyon
le maire sortant un soutien de la
première heure de la république en marge
gérard collomb a également voté il
brigue la présidence de la métropole
lyonnaise une élection compliquée dans
la troisième ville de france à la tête
de la mairie depuis 2001 l'ancien
socialiste pourrait pâtir de son passage
éclair de 16 mois au ministère de
l'intérieur en 2017 2018
et puis du côté du rassemblement
national dans son fief d'hénin-beaumont
la mer rassemblement national le maire
pardon à steve brio is a été réélu dès
le premier tour ce soir information qui
émane de son entourage à vérifier donc
au fil de cette soirée un peu plus tôt
vous voyez la présidente du
rassemblement national s'était rendu
dans son bureau de vote dans une ville
quasi déserte elle est venue accompagnée
justement de steeve briois maire sortant
de cette commune de 27 mille habitants
et candidat à sa propre succession et
pour en parler alexis poulin directeur
et cofondateur du monde moderne est avec
nous en direct depuis 20 scène alexis
poulain bonsoir m merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur rt france alors il ya bien
sûr des enjeux politiques ce soir mais
est ce que c'est la situation sanitaire
qui semble finalement plus préoccuper
les citoyens à ce soir évidemment je
crois que ces municipales n'intéresse
que ceux qui souhaitent et élus les
citoyens qui ont fait leurs devoirs dont
je fais partie se sont posés la question
longtemps saute il y aller est ce un
devoir d'y aller ou un devoir de ne pas
y aller et si on écoute certains
médecins il ne fallait pas y aller et je
regrette d'y être allé d'une certaine
façon mais comment faire dans cette
candide dans ces conditions-là
l'incapacité de choix l'inaction de ce
gouvernement pendant des semaines amène
la crise sanitaire on apprend la mort
d'un soignant dans le grand test des
remontées des médecins du front parce
que c'est un front face à ce virus qui
font part de leur inquiétude du fait de
notre système de santé qui serait
incapable de gérer le nombre de malades
qui vont arriver
on attend évidemment les mesures de
confinement qui ne vont pas tarder je
pense cette semaine le discours la prise
de parole du premier ministre hier soir
avant les municipales poser la question
pourquoi avoir maintenu ces municipales
ne fallait-il pas les annuler
aujourd'hui on voit le taux de
participation des gens ont fait ce choix
aussi d'aller voter
mais bon sang pourquoi les nouvelles
d'italie sont très mauvaises également
malgré les mesures de confinement c'est
encore plus de 300 morts aujourd'hui
plus de 3000 cas aujourd'hui l'europe
est maintenant le centre mondial de la
pandémie
on sent bien que les réponses des
différents gouvernements ne sont pas en
ordre de bataille et sont extrêmement
éparses et extrêmement
loin derrière la crise qui nous attend
malheureusement je crois que ces
municipales il faut arrêter d'en parler
tout simplement parce que ce n'est pas
ce qui inquiète ce qui intéresse les
françaises qui veut savoir c'est est ce
que on a les moyens de sauver des vies
est ce qu'on a des moyens de faire face
à l'épidémie de coronavirus et on
l'apprend ce soir alexis poulain le
bilan en france est passé à 120 morts et
5400 cas en france vous disiez on
s'achemine peut-être vers le scénario
italien on se demande même ici pourquoi
on va commenter une soirée électorale
qui finalement va peut-être être annulé
un j'imagine que c'est un casse tête
juridique pour pour ceux qui vont s'en
sont chargés si on passe en confinement
il n'y aura pas de deuxième tour
pourquoi donner les résultats dans ces
cas là est ce qu'on ferait pas mieux de
justement de ne pas commenter pour ne
pas donner des éléments pour un pour un
second éventuel tous le même village et
y ce plan bien sûr toute la gestion de
ce gouvernement est catastrophique
depuis le début de cette crise que ce
soit agnès buzyn qui disait elle sourit
relève que le virus ne viendrait pas en
france qui avait très peu de chance
c'était en janvier sur le fait qu'ils
avaient pas assez de masquer que
finalement les masques ne protégeait pas
c'est pas grave si bête ndiaye et qui
rigolaient sur les plateaux enfin c'est
pas possible
ces incapables mène dans le mur est
aujourd'hui avoir maintenu les élections
pour les annuler ce soir mais enfin qui
sont ces gens où est le jeu peut bien
qu'ils aient des problèmes juridiques il
fallait l'article 16 certainement pas
c'est certainement parce qu'on veut mais
on attend enfin gouverner c'est prévoir
on avait les alertes de nos amis
italiens depuis quinze jours qu'ils ne
fait pas la même erreur que nous
prenaient de la vence on n'a pas pris
d'avancé
aujourd'hui on se retrouve face à un mur
avec des élections c'est ridicule de les
voir se faire filmer en train de voter
butin qui est incapable de mettre du gel
sur ses mains philippe qui touche la
machine enfin c'est c'est scandaleux
proprement scandaleux je n'ai pas de
mots ce soir je suis en colère parce que
j'apprends la mort de soignants dans le
grand est
parce que j'apprends le manque encore de
moyens et ce qui risque de venir
aujourd'hui je trouve proprement
scandaleuse premier tour et la façon
dont le gouvernement a géré cette crise
depuis le début et je pense ne pas être
le seul dans ce cas là et être en colère
ce soir marine le pen la présidente du
rassemblement national dénonce un depuis
le début
l'amateurisme du gouvernement on le voit
les premières estimations ce soir pour
le rassemblement national sont plutôt
favorables en tout cas à hénin-beaumont
avec steeve briois est ce que il ya eu
un effet finalement coronavirus vous
pensé dans ces municipales évidemment je
pense que les petits partis et l'intérêt
à mobiliser leurs électeurs en disant
petits partis ce n'est pas le fn en
france mais de dire c'est l'occasion ou
jamais de faire un score parce que là on
peut mobiliser les troupes et voir la
différence
donc forcément c'est ces résultats ne
peuvent pas être pris pour ce qu'ils
sont c'est à dire que entre ceux qui ont
choisi de ne pas aller voter pour
protéger leur famille ou qui ne pouvait
pas ou qu'ils avaient peur de voter la
façon dont on a présenté ces élections
en disant qu'elles sont sûres mais on a
vu le nombre de bureaux de vote qui
n'ont pas été sécurisé où les consignes
n'ont pas été respectées
je crois que c'est ça ne sert à rien en
fait ce premier tour sachant que le
confinement qui vient s'il vient et bien
annulera defacto le deuxième tour enfin
enfin l'amateurisme flagrant aujourd'hui
ne doit pas faire se réjouir quelques
quelques directeurs responsables de
partis qui ont créé un sport aujourd'hui
on a vu donc près d'un français sur deux
qui sont allés voter on a vu aussi les
parcs aujourd'hui jour de vos tanks
france rempli de monde
alexis poulain est ce que c'est pas
aussi un problème de 2stv sme d'attitude
tout simplement de des français
complètement je critiquais en première
partie
d'abord la façon dont le gouvernement a
communiqué sur cette crise parce que on
a entendu des soi disant spécialistes
dire que ce n'était pas pire qu'une
grippe je pense à des romain goupil ad
michel cymes qui ont rassuré les
populations dont vous inquiétez pas
finalement ça va passer on peut le
prendre à être un porteur sain et puis
ça passera toute cette communication du
tout va très bien madame la marquise
elle a fait que les français aujourd'hui
sur les responsables elle a fait
qu'aujourd'hui les français on les a vus
s'agglutiner dans les marchés saluent
tinée dans les parcs faire en sorte de
faire des manifestations sauvages à
bordeaux par exemple ou hier ne pas
respecter la consigne à minuit et
continue de faire la fête jusqu'à 6h du
matin à un moment la responsabilité elle
est collective
il y a bien sûr une responsabilité
légale dans le fait de la gestion de la
crise par les autorités et c'est de là
elle peut être totalement critiquer mais
la gestion responsable des français
aujourd'hui elle est tout autant
critiquable et c'est lamentable de
image aujourd'hui qu'on a vu compte tenu
de l'ampleur de la crise que à laquelle
on a affaire merci beaucoup et alexis
poulain d'avoir répondu à nos questions
en direct sur rt france ce soir
mais alors avant de poursuivre thomas
bonnet de nouvelles estimations qui sont
tombés oui de nouvelles estimations avec
d'abord les ministres du gouvernement on
en parlait tout à l'heure
edouard philippe donc au havre
récolterait pour les premières
estimations qui nous parviennent 43% des
suffrages
gérald darmanin serait réélu au premier
tour à tourcoing et puis sur son compte
twitter franck riester le ministre de la
culture explique affirme qu'il serait
réélu vais également avec 58 points 85 %
des suffrages en mots sur des
estimations à lille où martine aubry
récolterait 30% des suffrages suivi par
la candidate europe ecologie les verts
qui récolterait pour sa part 23 et demi
pour cent un mot sur enfin sur les
candidats du rassemblement national à
fréjus david rachline récolterez 51 5%
des suffrages et serait donc réélu dès
le premier tour et puis à l'instant
steeve briois qui est quand qu il était
candidat dans la ville d'hénin-beaumont
affirme qu'il serait donc réélu il
avance une estimation de 64 74 pardon %
des suffrages
merci beaucoup thomas gonnet on va
partir en corse à présent pour faire un
point justement sur le coronavirus lille
qui fait partie des régions les plus
touchées du pays les électeurs ont dans
l'ensemble redoubler de vigilance pour
se rendre aux urnes comme les français
en général d'ailleurs certains déplorent
malgré tout le maintien de ces élections
dans un contexte de crise sanitaire
majeure
écoutez ses réactions à la sortie des
bureaux de vote
oui on y pense bien sûr mais bon si on
est raisonnable et qu'on suit les
consignes je pense que je devrais aller
correctement bah j'ai tout prévu parce
que je préférais prendre vos propos
liquide plutôt que d'en prendre à ceux
qui en ont réellement besoin à savoir
les hôpitaux
voilà donc puisque les élections ont
lieu j'y suis mais j'aurais préféré
qu'elle soit reportée la situation en
tant que professionnels de la
restauration je le trouve un petit peu
dommageable qu'on nous demande de fermer
les établissements et qu'en même temps
on autorise
on autorise les élections ça va un peu
dans c'est complètement à l'opposé
ces deux décisions qui sont à mon sens
ces responsables le bilan du du
coronavirus qui s'alourdit donc en
france en plein municipal les experts
d'ailleurs qui se prononceront peut-être
mardi sur l'opportunité d'un second tour
on vient de l'apprendre sachez aussi que
le le président l'est républicain
christian jacob a été testé positif aux
coronavirus aujourd'hui il est passé le
bilan en france à 120 morts et 5400 cas
selon le ministère de la santé
dans ce contexte les tribunaux français
seront fermés à partir de demain sauf
pour le traitement des contentieux est
essentielle à une disposition qui
s'ajoute donc à celle d'hier annoncé par
edouard philippe la france est à l'arrêt
après le passage au stade 3 de
l'épidémie du coronavirus tous les lieux
publics non indispensables sont fermés
depuis minuit hier soir et donc c'est la
ruée pour certains dans les commerces
alimentaires en voyez le reportage de
clément hospital les rideaux du
supermarché se lève à peine que des
dizaines de personnes s'engouffrent à
l'intérieur la peur du confinement
général et de la pénurie pousse de
nombreux français à faire des stocks
dans leur viseur les pâtes le riz ou
encore le papier toilette c'est la dèche
n'y a plus rien on croirait que c'est la
panique c'est la fin du monde
il n'ya presque pratiquement plus rien
les gens ils s'acharnent sur les pattes
sur les gâteaux et tout ça mais j'ai
franchement c'est la dèche
on se demande s'il va voir vraiment la
fin du monde
j'ai fini par devoir le faire je viens
de prendre une dizaine de paquets de
pâtes alors que depuis le début je
critique cette façon de faire mais au
final j'ai pas le choix car j'ai passé
ma
journées entières à chercher un
malheureux sac de pâtes j'ai fait cinq
supermarchés encore moi j'habite vers la
place d'auteuil
enfin la porte d'auteuil pardon est
impossible de trouver des pâtes ou les
rayons dévaliser les sauces les machins
pour le ministre de l'économie et des
finances bruno le maire pas de panique
il n'y aura pas de pénurie en france et
pour garantir l'approvisionnement du
pays
les règles de recrutement de travail de
nuit et les heures supplémentaires
seront assouplies dans les supermarchés
aujourd'hui les représentants de la
grande distribution nous assure que 90 à
95% des références sont disponibles et
qu'elles continueront à être disponible
dans les jours et dans les semaines à
venir
il n'y a pas de difficultés en terme
d'approvisionnement en produits
alimentaires pour les français et n'y en
aura pas nous y veillons alors que le
seuil d'alerté sanitaire maximale est
activée le ministre de l'éducation jean
michel blanquer estime que plus de la
moitié des français pourrait être
contaminé par le corona virus et pour
lutter contre la propagation de
l'épidémie
elisabeth borgne a appelé à se déplacer
le moins possible il faut limiter des
transports de longue distance au strict
nécessaire s'agit pas de circuler d'une
agglomération à l'autre ça vaut
maintenant ça vaut pour les vacances les
rues de paris se désemplissent peu à peu
alors que de nombreux commerces et
restaurants au bcd rideau à la sortie de
son bureau de vote emmanuel macron
affirme que la vie minimum qui permet
d'aller se nourrir et de voter elle doit
continuer et avant de poursuivre sur ses
mesures sanitaires un rectificatif de
revenus ou une information circule sur
les réseaux sociaux selon laquelle l'un
des charges devant le chef du service de
réanimation de l'hôpital de colmar
serait décédée sachez que alors on vous
parle c'est une information que nous
sommes pas en mesure de confirmer
il semblerait que les choses se soient
un petit peu emballé sur les réseaux
sociaux on vit dans une chambre a
évidemment informés de l'évolution de la
santé éventuellement de ce chef de
service
merci thomas alors les mesures
sanitaires on y revient annoncé hier
soir un coup dur pour les restaurateurs
pour autant certains d'entre eux ne
compte pas rester inactif illustration
au coeur de la capitale où un restaurant
se lance dans la vente à emporter
objectif
écoutez écouler les stocks et éviter des
pertes financières trop importantes
le premier syndicat du secteur eu un
village se dit solidairement engagé pour
traverser cette crise
la première chose que j'ai faite c'est
j'ai bien regardé si la vente à emporter
et la vente à livrer c'est à dire les
plateaux aux livres et ne rentrait pas
dans le décret apparemment c'est un
autre pas dans le décret je dis bien
apparemment parce que les choses peuvent
changer les choses changent de jour en
jour donc on a un souci par rapport à ça
mais pour l'instant je veux faire de la
vente en porte et vous voyez on est à un
mètre des quarts et je vais faire de la
vente à emporter les gens vont me
commander la carte habituelle qui est là
et puis on va leur faire ça dans des
telles que wayne et des plats à emporter
et vont partir avec ça qu'ils vont payer
moins cher bien sûr que si ottawa ce
temps que moi en 35 ans de carrière je
me suis jamais retrouvé au chômage quoi
donc ça me fait bizarre je n'avais
jamais pensé imaginé même me retrouver
au chômage un jour quoi donc là et je
sais pas l'avenir ce que va donner quoi
et voilà donc pour cette page spéciale
municipal et coronavirus bien sûr on va
y revenir longuement à partir de 21h
dans notre spécial élections municipales
sachez ce soir que des politiques
s'élève justement contre la tenue de ces
élections et demandent le report de
cette élection municipale c'est le cas
notamment de gênes
yannick jadot d'europe écologie les
verts c'est la fin de ce journal merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans 30
minutes un peu plus de trente minutes
maintenant avec olivier
restez avec nous sur est fausse
[Musique]
il ya une première chose que je pense
qui est importante c'est que les états
que ce soit la france ou la belgique
reconnaissent cette situation reconnaît
ce qui a eu des adoptions illégales cela
concernait combien d'enfants
les chiffres exacts ne sont pas très
clair mais plusieurs